[Music]
so
we've talked a little bit about
temperature before
yes but i just want to just sort of do
it again
but all right i think the you know 10
minutes just isn't enough time to say
everything you need to say
about temperature we're still talking
about temperature that's correct okay
correct so let me first tell you
in the world of physics what temperature
is okay oh okay
temperature only has meaning
when you have an ensemble of particles
that are vibrating
okay okay okay so
okay
uh how fast is everything
vibrating
okay
and
you get oh how fast is this one and this
one and all sort of moving in
in different directions like the
molecules in a gas cloud or even even in
a solid object the particles are
vibrating right and you can ask
what is the average kinetic energy
energy of this motion of all those
particles so
okay let me just ask then
do
those vibrations from these particles
produce
some type of measurable energy like heat
yeah so they bang up against your
thermometer
and then the thermometer gives you a
reading oh
that is
that's kind of dope i'm liking it so far
that's okay so we're clean on that right
yes yeah no problem okay
so
what happens if you don't have any
particles
um
you should be really chilly
like
you need a glass of you need a cup of
tea it means you're chilling yeah yeah
yeah
yeah no how do you measure the
temperature of something
if you don't have a vibration particles
vibrating against so what happens in
that case is
because the vibrating molecules or
particles are not the only thing that
can put energy to your thermometer okay
okay
all right light can do the same thing
too or electromagnetic energy which
would includes light right
visible light so
light
goes to your
thermometer as well all right
but your thermometer has to be able to
absorb it
in order to then get a temperature for
you okay all right if you're trying to
find the temperature of the visible
light in this room
and your thermometer is made of
transparent glass the visible light goes
right through the glass and you won't
get the temperature of that light
okay so
so it's
temperature is not
a completely obvious thing
under certain circumstances that are
that are not even much of a stretch
okay so i'll give you another example i
once calculated
dare i say famously calculated
how long it would take to cook a
16-inch pepperoni pizza pepperoni pizza
on the windowsill of your home on the
planet venus okay is this gluten-free
we're talking no
[Laughter]
and did you make that calculation
i didn't do the gluten factor okay the
gluten correction i didn't make right so
here's what happens the atmosphere in
venus has like a hundred times
as many particles in it per volume so
it's 100 times as dense
so so there you have it your pizza in
the oven and there's hot air hitting it
but i have a hundred times as much hot
air hitting it
okay olive venus is one big
convection pizza pizza oven right so
there it is all right but
and
the air is hotter
okay the air is like 900 degrees
fahrenheit
so
so and a pizza oven is only around 500
degrees fahrenheit so
so what you have a hundred times the
atmospheric
uh contact
and 500 more fahrenheit degrees
to boot so i calculate if it takes 15
minutes to cook a pizza and you do the
fractions and you do this right i did it
i got about seven seconds between seven
and nine so
to cook a pepperoni pizza well no and
and we'll be there in 30 minutes or less
guaranteed baby
guaranteed
well yeah there's a two it's seven and
nine seconds around there so then as
i've told you before
the geek spectrum
knows no limits
and who's and who occupies it all right
as i say that all the time when our good
friend charles chelsea was a boy right
so i put this out there and i and
somebody called me out and said dr tyson
you neglected the radiant energy
just from the gas being hot
that's in addition
to the molecular contact energy that's
going on at the pizza surface
and if you included that
the pizza gets cooked in like two or
three seconds
right
not the seven seconds so it's not only
the transfer of heat from the vibrating
molecules there's the
infrared light
that's coming out of the warm oven not
only the air itself but the walls of the
cavity that's why pizza ovens are brick
ovens because the ideal one's because
the oven is radiating to the pizza right
top of the air yeah everything around it
is hot everything around it is hot so
it's it's it so the pizza is lose is is
is gaining
energy
from the air molecules
directly and from the walls of the oven
indirectly because of the radiant um uh
influx of of infrared in that case okay
so there's these two ways so if you have
a thermometer in the vacuum of space
right what matters is how much of the
photons of light is the thermometer
absorbing
so if you wrap the thermometer in
reflective mylar
then the temperature will just keep
dropping
until it reaches the temperature of the
whole universe which is damn near
zero degrees right kelvins yeah absolute
zero
so
the temperature has to do with what are
you wearing
uh oh wait a minute we've heard this
before i'm sorry i i thought we were
doing that thing
well you know chuck what are you wearing
what are you wearing
knows who are you wearing chuck yeah
right oh yeah yeah that's the red carpet
way did you wear it well so
when they say
wear lighter clothes in the summer right
what they're saying is the air will have
whatever temperature it does
but you don't want to and it's going to
be hot probably but you don't want to
add to that by absorbing light from the
sun
because that will just add more
temperature
that's why in the summer time i just
wear bike reflectors
it's if you do that i didn't walk around
with bike reflectors on that's all
you'll get if if so if you just clad
your body with bike bicycle reflectors
or something that is good at reflecting
sunlight which could just be
by the way it's been rumored that you
know all futuristic sci-fi
um
space things that people wear they're
always reflective you have silver
they're always silver it could be
because they're living too close to
their host star
and they have to keep reflecting it off
to stay cool
point is you cannot speak
singularly about the temperature of the
air in any way that matters to you
if you're also exposed to
light
that could be absorbed
by what you're wearing
so in the winter
it's cold out you want as much extra
energy as you can get so where dark
clothes the dark clothes absorb sunlight
and then the temperature inside your
clothes goes higher than would otherwise
be if it was just if you were just
measuring the air
right that's that is why
in the wintertime i hang out with my
black friends and in the summer time i
hang out with my white friends
and i'm always
at the right time
i'm in the goldilocks spot always
and in the fall and winter you say oh
can you back up a little come a little
no you move away exactly
in the fall and spring i just hang out
with puerto ricans
damn truckers want to get this show
cancelled
come on people y'all can't get mad at
that
come on that was pretty funny yeah
so i'm just saying temperature is just a
little more complicated than you might
otherwise think right that's all it's
not just
what is the air it's how fast are your
molecules vibrating and what is causing
that to vibrate and the air is how we
usually think about it but other things
can make that happen as well
so that that's what i'm saying and the
rules about
the thermometer that gives you the
official weather weather service
temperature
that thermometer is in a shadow it's not
open to the sunlight ah
okay in fact i i used to do this when i
was growing up i think they've corrected
this so the bank
temperature time signs you know you they
used to be on all remember time and
temperature time and temperature right i
would look at bank time and temperatures
that were in sunlight
and bank time and temperatures that were
in shade
and the official air temperature might
be 90 degrees the bank's model would say
105 degrees it's like no it's not okay
because you're sitting out in the
sunlight right and you're absorbing the
sun on top of the air temperature so
that's misrepresents what you would feel
standing in the air but in shadow
in the shadow of a tree for example
and when you walk under a tree say oh
it's cooler under the tree
the air is the same temperature so chuck
why is it cooler under the tree well the
absolute same as the shadow temperature
it's the absence of the light
being directly on you it's the absence
of the light that you would be absorbing
that would make you feel hotter it's not
just a feeling you're actually hotter
than the air temperature when you're
absorbing the sunlight wow that there
you go that's pretty cool man yeah so
that's just so temperature i could go on
and on there's a lot more to temperature
than just a reading that's
correct correct and one thing i said in
multiple shows and i'll say it again
the fact that you can see the sun in the
daytime
all right that's an obvious fact right
means the sunlight is
moving through the atmosphere and the
atmosphere is transparent to sunlight
okay
it's a visible light at least
so
and that visible light is where the
sun's energy peaks
so if the atmosphere is transparent to
the sun the sun is not heating the air
because the energy is going straight
through it
right oh man i mean well there you go
okay
so well
oh wait so then then what does it
finally hit at the ground the ground and
then the ground warms up and then the
ground is in physical contact with the
air and the ground heats the air
so chuck holding aside an exotic upper
layer of the atmosphere what i'm
generally telling you is what is the
hottest part of the earth's atmosphere
uh right next to the ground right next
to the ground and as you ascend the
temperature drops as we all know if you
paid any attention at all to the data on
the screen in an airplane and what's the
temperature outside the airplane 40
below zero right
so icarus had it all wrong
he didn't fly too close to the right his
wings would have froze
they knew nothing about thermodynamics
right when they invented the story of
icarus that's pretty good as it ascends
to get close to the sun he would have
been farther away from the sun's source
of heat on earth
and the temperature would have dropped
and dropped and his wings would have
frozen and cracked he still would have
fallen um but for different reasons okay
all right chuck we gotta call it quits
there that's very cool i'm so uh yeah
who knew that was you always surprised
me man you always surprised me that's
the whole point of these i guess yeah i
didn't think we could get this much out
of temperature
temperatures
i didn't who knew there was this was
going on with temperature and let me
just say if you go high enough in the
atmosphere you reach the ozone layer
right what does the ozone do oh it
protects us from radiation and and yeah
from and hardware
comfort rays of the sun okay so to
protect us it means it absorbs it
nice okay so tell me about the
temperature of the ozone layer
it must be really hot it gets hot and so
in fact if you look at the temperature
profile of our atmosphere the
temperature drops
until you get to what we call the
thermosphere and the temperature goes
back up
because in that layer
the chemistry of the atmosphere
is absorbing ultraviolet rays from the
sun
and that heats that layer
and protects us down here on the surface
that's very cool there you go there you
go all right
well the only thing i really took away
from this whole thing is that on venus
no one ever says who touched the
thermostat
plus delivered in 30 minutes or less is
way too long if they don't cook your
pizza in four seconds
nice all right that's it chuck we're out
of here okay start talk keep looking up
[Music]
you